This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Sentental. Acquare the competences
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之百真人。你有渴望去发挥真正的不同吗？LaCite学院为你提供“依赖与老年护理”项目。获取必备的技能
essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the health and dependents. Construise a career enriching to service
以陪伴和支持面临健康和依赖问题的人。开启一段丰富多彩的职业生涯，服务
of the community francophone of all the country. Don't the quality in French, it's possible
全国各地的法语社区。不会法语也没关系，
with the City. Visit Collage LaC. .A. today, An initiative of the Consortium National
在La Cite学院一切皆有可能。今天就访问CollageLaC.A.，这是法国国家
of Formation in Health Supposed by Santee Canada. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the woman that saw the murder
健康培训联合会的倡议，并得到加拿大卫生部的支持。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变得漆黑。这把我吓坏了。恶魔，醒醒。我是看到克里瓦奇和德皮波
take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey
行凶的那个女人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出丝毫悔意，在被判处最高刑罚时显得无动于衷。我说，我是无辜的。我要将上诉进行到底。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方，收听“骨谷”节目中的《恶魔采石场》。快乐至关重要，它也难以捉摸，但现在有一个令人兴奋的新方法来开启你的旅程
toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS.
走向更加快乐的生活。“快乐101”。这是一个全新播客，由我霍达·科特比主持。如果你渴望获得灵感来最大化你的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的现场聊天。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索“快乐101”并立即收听。由CVS为您呈现的由霍达·科特比主持的“快乐101”。
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Chichariot-O-Nand-es,
每个人都把我当成足球运动员，但在成为任何东西之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，我仍在学习如何与我出生以来的问题、错误、人际关系、情绪共存。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、真诚的。只有关于活着意味着什么的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·奇查里托·奥尔内斯，
and listen to learning to be human. on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. June is Black Music Month, and on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture, like Sway Lee. Do you realize how legendary you are? I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got, like, so much more to do. Like, Prince, he dropped like 30 albums.
在iHeartRadio、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听“学习做人”。六月是黑人音乐月，在Drink Champs播客中，我们与文化界最热门的大咖进行交流，比如斯韦·李。你意识到自己有多传奇了吗？我很感激。我会这么说，但我心里想，天哪，我还有好多事要做。就像普林斯，他发了大约30张专辑。
We dropped, like, five right now. That's the rate we got to be going. Yep, that's a good attitude. No matter the era, Drink Chams brings you the biggest names and the most unfiltered conversation. Listen to Drink Chams from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Speg and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another.
我们现在才发了大约五张。这就是我们必须前进的速度。是的，这是一种好态度。无论哪个时代，Drink Champs都会为你带来最大牌的人物和最原汁原味的对话。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方，收听来自Black Effect播客网络的Drink Champs。大家好。我是杰玛·斯佩格，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时最大的变化、时刻和转折点，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到这个播客。很高兴你能回来收听另一个
episode. Not much chit-chat this morning, guys, not much small talk because we have a big episode, a big episode on something that I have been thinking about a lot recently, which is how normalized it has become to actively hate yourself and how almost hated you are online, in person, in the real world, if you say or show that you love yourself. How in the world did we get here? Why does that make any sense? and to perhaps get a little bit conspiratorial on you all, who is benefiting from this? Who is benefiting from this system of self-loving? Who set this all up so that self-hatred is the status quo and self-love is the thing that
单集。今天早上没有太多的闲聊，朋友们，没有太多的寒暄，因为我们有一期重磅节目，一期关于我最近一直在思考的事情的重磅节目，那就是：主动厌恶自己是多么的正常，以及如果你说或表现出你爱自己，你在网上、在现实生活中会变得多么招人讨厌。我们到底是怎么走到这一步的？这有什么道理吗？为了带大家稍微探索一点阴谋论，到底是谁从中受益？谁从这种自我热爱的体系中受益？这一切是谁设定的，以至于自我厌恶成了常态，而自爱
is seen as sinful or bad? It just seems to me a little bit ridiculous. And I also personally think it's keeping a lot of us stuck in places that we don't want to be. I've been saying this so much on the podcast recently. in so many different episodes, you can't hate yourself into a successful life. And I thought, you know, there's only so many times I can say that before I just do a full freaking episode on it. And today is that day. We're going to look at the science and the psychology
被视为一种罪恶或不好的事情？在我看来这有点荒谬。而且我也个人认为，这让我们的许多人陷入了我们不想呆的地方。我最近在播客中经常这么说。在许多不同的单集中，你不可能通过厌恶自己来过上成功的生活。我想，你知道的，在我真正做一期完整的节目之前，我说这话的次数是有限的。而今天就是那个日子。我们将探讨科学和心理学
that proves you cannot hate yourself into a successful life. And yeah, essentially just dissects where your self-hatred comes from and why it's lying to you. You know, it's not going to make you humble. It's not going to make you more successful because of that humility. You cannot bully yourself into being better. Even if it gets momentary results, it is not a long-term motivational force, the way that we tend to think it will be. This is a big episode today. We have a lot to explore. I really particularly want to drill into the origins of this feeling and of this like psychological self-loathing. And then also, of course, provide some evidence-based strategies to eliminate that mindset,
来证明你不可能通过厌恶自己来过上成功的生活。是的，本质上就是剖析你的自我厌恶从何而来，以及为什么它在对你撒谎。你知道，这不会让你变得谦逊。它不会因为这种谦逊而让你变得更成功。你无法通过霸凌自己来变得更好。即使它能带来短暂的结果，它也不是一种长期的动力源泉，就像我们倾向于认为的那样。今天是重要的一集。我们有很多东西要探讨。我特别想深入探讨这种感觉和这种心理自我厌恶的起源。然后，当然，还要提供一些基于证据的策略来消除这种心态，
especially if you were in your 20s, because if there was going to be a time in your life where you really needed to have a deep sense of self-belief, it would be this time. It would be right now. So I feel like if you are struggling with self-doubt and self-belief, loathing that has become insidious and is bleeding into everything that you're doing. This is the perfect episode for you. Without further ado, let's talk about why hating yourself will get you nowhere you want to be. And of course, the alternative.
特别是如果你正处于二十岁，因为如果你生命中真的需要一种深厚的自信感，那就是这个时候。就是现在。所以我觉得如果你正在与自我怀疑作斗争，而这种深入骨髓并渗透到你所做的一切中的厌恶感正在影响你。这就是为你量身打造的完美节目。闲话少说，让我们来聊聊为什么厌恶自己会让你到不了任何你想去的地方。当然，还有替代方案。
Stay with us. Let's start here. Why does it feel easier to hate ourselves rather than love ourselves? Like, instinctually, why does it feel easier to dismiss a complex? or to be self-deprecating in front of other people or why does it feel easier to focus in on all the things we dislike about our bodies and dislike about our personalities and dislike about our work ethic rather than the things that we like. That doesn't come from nowhere. And the best evidence that this is an external influence first and foremost that becomes internalized,
请留下来。让我们从这里开始。为什么比起爱自己，我们觉得厌恶自己更容易？就像，从直觉上讲，为什么我们觉得忽视一种复杂情结更容易？或者在别人面前贬低自己更容易，或者为什么我们觉得把注意力集中在我们不喜欢自己的身体、不喜欢自己的性格、不喜欢自己工作习惯的所有事情上，比关注我们喜欢的事情更容易。这并非空穴来风。最好的证据表明，这首先是一种外在影响，然后被内化，
the best evidence for this is being around children, right? Being around kids. kids and seeing that before the age of four or five, children have no concept that there is something about themselves that could be unlikable. Like that is not even something that enters their consciousness. They don't even, they don't even think about it. But then it's almost like there comes a point where a switch gets flipped, a switch gets turned. My friend actually, she has two kids, one who is three and one who was eight. I was watching them the other day and we were doing arts and craft and like the younger one is just like scribbling, she's having fun and like doesn't really care, it's like exploring. And the eight year old was like this one isn't good. Like this
最好的证据就是和孩子们在一起，对吧？和孩子们在一起。孩子们在四五岁之前，没有任何概念认为自己身上有什么地方是不讨人喜欢的。这甚至不是进入他们意识的东西。他们甚至不，甚至都不会去想它。但随后仿佛到了某个时刻，一个开关被拨动了，一个开关被打开了。我的朋友其实有两个孩子，一个三岁，一个八岁。前几天我看着他们，我们在做美术和手工艺，较小的那个只是在乱涂乱画，她玩得很开心，真的不在乎，就像是在探索。而那个八岁的孩子却说，这个不好。这个
one is bad. My art is bad. Like I have to start over again. And just like the parallel like the juxtaposition between these two people was like quite striking. So where does this come from? When does this self-loving first hit? Psychology will tell us that a lot of self-hatred starts as a form of adaptation. When we're young, we don't yet have like a fully formed, stable sense of self. So we often borrow our reflections and borrow our sense of identity from other people who we spend a lot of time around. parents, teachers, siblings, peers, they kind of help us build the first draft of how you understand yourself by offering suggestions, but sometimes also offering criticism and also by displaying self-criticism towards themselves. This is what we call, this first sense of self is
不好。我的艺术作品不好。我得重新开始。这两个人之间的这种平行对比可以说是相当鲜明的。那么这来自哪里？这种自我热爱最初是什么时候出现的？心理学告诉我们，很多自我厌恶都是作为一种适应形式开始的。当我们年轻的时候，我们还没有形成一个完全形成、稳定的自我感。所以我们经常从我们花很多时间陪伴的其他人的身上借用我们的倒影和身份感。父母、老师、兄弟姐妹、同龄人，他们通过提供建议，但也通过提供批评，以及通过对自己表现出自我批评，来帮助我们建立对自我理解的初稿。这就是我们所说的，这种最初的自我感是
what we call the evaluative self. We learn about what it means to be human by seeing what others are doing, thinking about what others are doing, copying other people's behaviors, and also comparing our own behavior or our own little lives to what we see around us. At some point, we become aware that there is an audience. We're not always performing for the same audience, though. We become aware as children there is an audience. Some of our childhood audiences were a lot meaner. Some of our parents weren't very nice. Some of our peers weren't very nice. Some of our teachers weren't very nice. Some of our teachers weren't very nice. If those early environments are warm, you often learn that mistakes are survivable and that your worth will remain intact, even when you get things wrong, even when you're
我们所说的评估性自我。我们通过观察别人的行为、思考别人的行为、模仿别人的行为，以及将我们自己的行为或我们的小生活与我们周围看到的东西进行比较，来了解做人意味着什么。在某个时刻，我们意识到有一个观众。不过，我们并不总是为同一个观众表演。作为孩子，我们意识到有一个观众。我们童年的一些观众要苛刻得多。我们的一些父母不是很友善。我们的一些同龄人不是很友善。我们的一些老师不是很友善。我们的一些老师不是很友善。如果这些早期的环境是温暖的，你通常会了解到错误是可以挺过去的，你的价值会保持完好，即使你把事情搞砸了，即使你
not perfect, you're happy to explore, you're happy to bounce back, you're happy to, you just are resilient. Like, I think about my friend's kid, right? Yeah, she didn't like her art, but just because she didn't like it when it was compared to, like, the idea of somebody else's picture, right? Not because her parents were like screaming at her that she was terrible at everything she does like she didn't like it from a comparative sense for some people though like their environment like the inner critic was always external it was a highly critical rejecting humiliating unpredictable cruel completely disengaged person who was like speaking things in their ear telling them they were terrible Children are watching so closely. They are listening so closely and they internalize the tone of our own language, not just towards them, but towards ourselves as well.
并不完美，你也很乐意去探索，你乐意去恢复，你乐意去，你只是很有韧性。比如，我想到了我朋友的孩子，对吧？是的，她不喜欢她的艺术作品，但这只是因为当它与别人的画作的想法进行比较时，她不喜欢它，对吧？而不是因为她的父母对她大喊大叫，说她做任何事都很糟糕——她不喜欢它是从比较的意义上来说的。然而，对某些人来说，他们的环境——内心的批评者——总是外在的。这是一个高度批判、排斥、羞辱、不可预测、残酷、完全脱离的人，他们在他们耳边说话，告诉他们他们很糟糕。孩子们看得太仔细了。他们听得太仔细了，他们内化了我们自己语言的基调，不仅是对他们的，也是对我们自己的。
Research has consistently found that higher self-criticism and self-hatred as an adult, if you have more of those things as an adult, it's greatly associated with early memories of parental rejection or conditional affection from parents, but also, from favoritism, from, favoritism from teachers, from childhood bullying, basically just harmful experiences that occurred right as we were forming our evaluative self. For example, there was a 2006 study published in the Journal of Effective Disorders, and it looked at the impact of childhood verbal abuse on how adults view themselves. They analyzed the data of like 6,000 people, And they found that heavy or high levels of criticism and discipline and like non-purposeful discipline experiencing that as a child has a really significant impact on the development of things like adult depression and adult anxiety.
研究一致发现，成年后更高的自我批评和自我厌恶，如果你成年后有更多这些东西，它与父母早期拒绝或有条件关爱的记忆有很大关系，而且还与老师的偏爱、童年霸凌有关，基本上就是刚好在我们形成评估性自我时发生的有害经历。例如，2006年发表在《情感障碍杂志》上的一项研究探讨了童年言语虐待对成年人如何看待自己的影响。他们分析了大约6,000人的数据，他们发现，在童年时期经历大量或高度的批评、纪律以及无目的的纪律，对成年后抑郁和焦虑等事物的发展产生了非常显著的影响。
The researchers described the role as self-criticism in these studies as basically a full mediator. So this basically means that the verbal abuse didn't. directly cause the depression, but it causes a child to develop a self-critical brain, because of course they're going to believe what an adult says about them. They're the role model. They're the adult. And that self-critical brain is what drives some parts or a lot of parts of adult depression. A similar story is definitely seen in terms of pure experiences as well. When we're kids, when we are teenagers, this weird social like pecking order can emerge as people kind of like fight to promote their evaluative selves and to feel good about themselves. Like the main way that we feel good
研究人员在这些研究中将自我批评的角色描述为一个完全的中介。这基本上意味着言语虐待并没有直接导致抑郁，但它导致了一个孩子发展出一个自我批评的大脑，因为他们当然会相信成年人对他们的看法。他们是榜样。他们是成年人。而那个自我批评的大脑正是驱动成年抑郁部分或很大一部分原因的所在。同理，在同辈经验方面也肯定能看到类似的故事。当我们还是孩子，当我们是青少年时，随着人们为了提升自己的评估性自我并对自己感觉良好而展开斗争，这种奇怪的社交等级秩序就会出现。作为儿童和青少年，我们对自己感觉良好的主要方式，
about ourselves as children and teenagers is in reference to other people. And so to feel better, we often have to result to criticizing others, bullying, making remarks, jokes, feeling a sense of superiority, that sort of thing. Of course, that's not always the case, but it's very, very prevalent, and that definitely reinforces the self-hatred of the person being targeted, for sure. It also reinforces the self-hatred of the person doing the targeting. Like, there is a reason that as teenagers, when we are insecure, we feel the need to diminish somebody else. And it means that, like, every person in this situation feels terrible. This is why self-hatred can feel so intimate, because it starts so, so young.
是对照其他人。因此，为了感觉更好，我们经常不得不诉诸批评他人、欺凌、发表言论、开玩笑、感到一种优越感，诸如此类。当然，情况并非总是如此，但这是非常非常普遍的，这绝对会增强被针对者的自我厌恶。它也增强了实施针对者的自我厌恶。就像，有一个原因，即作为青少年，当我们没有安全感时，我们觉得有必要贬低别人。这意味着，这种情况下的每个人都感觉糟糕透顶。这就是为什么自我厌恶会感到如此亲密，因为它开始得太早、太早了。
Someone else's voice, when heard enough times with enough authority or emotional force, can stick with us and form part of who we think we are. Eventually, like, if this criticism becomes loud enough, it no longer needs somebody else to be present. Like, we inherently believe that, yes, we aren't that talented. Yes, we aren't that attractive. Yes, we aren't that smart. yes, we aren't somebody that others want to be around because we're hearing it from maybe a parent, we're hearing it from teachers, we're hearing it from peers. And then something even more complicated
当听到足够多次、具有足够权威或情感力量时，别人的声音可以留在我们身边，并构成我们认为自己是谁的一部分。最终，如果这种批评变得足够大声，它就不再需要别人的出席。我们天生相信，是的，我们没有那么有才华。是的，我们没有那么有吸引力。是的，我们没有那么聪明。是的，我们不是别人想要陪伴的人，因为我们从父母那里听到过，我们从老师那里听到过，我们从同龄人那里听到过。然后发生了一些更复杂的事情。
happens. Self-hatred starts to feel useful because it feels so normal. Sometimes, I don't know, we end up hating ourselves as a form of self-protection, thinking that, you know, if I criticize myself enough, if I criticize myself before anybody else can, I get to feel prepared. If I make fun of myself first, I'm in control of the humiliation instead of waiting to be surprised by it. That is why self-hatred can feel so oddly comforting because it is familiar, because we take what other people have said about us, we become so normalized and comfortable around it. We begin to feel like, well, if we do it before them, then we can make this thing useful. This is one of the biggest myths about the inner critic, that if you stopped tearing yourself
自我厌恶开始让人觉得有用，因为它太正常了。有时，我不知道，我们最终讨厌自己是为了自我保护，心想，你知道的，如果我足够批评自己，如果我在别人之前批评自己，我就能感到有准备。如果我先取笑自己，我就能掌控羞辱，而不是等待被它惊艳。这就是为什么自我厌恶会让人感到如此诡异的安慰，因为它很熟悉，因为我们接受了别人对我们的评价，我们在它周围变得如此正常化和舒适。我们开始觉得，如果我们抢在他们前面去做，那么我们就能让这件事变得有用。这是关于内在批评者的最大迷思之一，即如果你停止自我撕裂，
apart, you would become lazy, you would become indulgent, you would become complacent, unambitious, you would become morally kind of soft. And there is this kind of cultural admiration for harshness, especially when it is directed inwards that we actually tend to confuse with discipline. Like we act like being emotionally brutal with ourselves is evidence that we are willing to push ourselves, that we are willing to push our ego aside, and therefore we must be a good person, we must be a hardworking person, we must be a worthy person. Psychologically, that makes sense. And it makes sense why people end up here, end up in this state of just like constant self-loathing without even realizing it.
你就会变得懒惰、放纵、沾沾自喜、没有野心，你在道德上也会变得有点软弱。这种文化对严厉有一种钦佩，特别是当它朝向内心时，我们实际上往往将其与纪律混为一谈。就像我们表现得对自己的情感残酷是证明我们愿意推动自己，我们愿意把自我放在一边，因此我们一定是一个好人，我们一定是一个勤奋的人，我们一定是一个有价值的人。从心理学上讲，这讲得通。这也解释了为什么人们最终会走到这一步，陷入这种持续的自我厌恶状态，甚至没有意识到这一点。
If you grew up in environments where, you know, your parents were also harsh towards themselves as well, not just towards you or harsh to each other, you know, you also have a higher chance of internalizing self-hatred as a normal part of life. For example, if you had a mother or a father who was always criticizing or complaining about their body as a way to force themselves to stick to diets, which I feel like is a lot more common than we realize, and I'm sure a lot of you can relate, your mind then learns that hatred equals motivation and motivation equals progress. We need hatred to make ourselves do the things and stick to the things that we said we were going to do. Here's the thing, and this may sound like I'm about to contradict myself, but stick with me.
如果你在一个父母对他们自己也很严厉的环境中长大，不仅对你严厉或彼此严厉，你知道，你内化自我厌恶作为生活正常部分的几率也会更高。例如，如果你有一个母亲或父亲，他们总是批评或抱怨自己的身材，以此来强迫自己坚持节食，我觉得这比我们意识到的要普遍得多，而且我相信你们很多人都能感同身受，你的大脑就会学到，仇恨等于动力，动力等于进步。我们需要仇恨来让自己做我们说过要做的事情并坚持下去。事情是这样的，这听起来可能我要自相矛盾了，但请听我说。
Self-hatred actually can act as a very potent, immediate motivator initially because it activates the brain's threat response, and it uses shame or frustration or rage as a force for change, essentially creating a very high pressure, panic-driven need to avoid perceived inadequacy. So initially, being motivated by self-hatred might actually get you to act, it might actually get you to do certain things, but it has a dual function. In one way, like, yes, it may get you to the start line, but as soon as you are ready to start or as soon as you are halfway through the race, that self-hatred that you relied upon to motivate you suddenly becomes the thing that is going to make this all about self-punishment,
自我厌恶实际上最初可以充当一种非常强大、直接的动力，因为它激活了大脑的威胁反应，并利用羞耻、沮丧或愤怒作为改变的力量，本质上创造了一种极高压力、由恐慌驱动的需求，以避免感知到的不足。因此，最初由自我厌恶驱动可能会让你采取行动，它实际上可能会让你做某些事情，但它具有双重功能。一方面，是的，它可能会让你到达起跑线，但一旦你准备好开始或者一旦你赛程过半，你赖以激励自己的自我厌恶突然就会变成让这一切变成自我惩罚的东西，
and it's suddenly going to become the thing that's going to make you feel like you are not capable. There is no off-switch. You use self-hatred for motivation. It will eventually demotivate you because inherent in your self-hatred is this feeling that you are not worthy, you are not capable, this hard thing that you are trying to do, you actually can't do it. So on the surface, it might seem that that like self-criticizing voice is helping you improve. But actually, that same inner voice has a much deeper, more profound, more wounding impact because it's simply, it's just not sustainable. And we know by now that
它突然会变成让你觉得自己没有能力的东西。没有关闭开关。你用自我厌恶来获取动力。它最终会让你失去动力，因为你的自我厌恶中固有一种感觉，即你不值得，你没有能力，你正试图做的这件难事，你其实做不到。因此，表面上看，那个自我批评的声音可能在帮你改进。但实际上，同一个内心的声音有着更深、更深远、更具创伤性的影响，因为它根本上是不可持续的。我们现在知道，
that same self-hatra will fuel burnout. It will fuel anxiety. It will have long-term negative impacts. there's this really fascinating 2022 study that measured levels of self-hatred, perfectionism and stress in 220 students in the UK. And this study found that self-hatred is one of, well, is actually the main driver for perfectionist tendencies. People are rarely perfectionist because they like themselves. They're perfectionists because they're searching for this final
同样的自我厌恶会加剧职业倦怠。它会加剧焦虑。它会产生长期的负面影响。这是一个非常迷人的2022年研究，它测量了英国220名学生的自我厌恶、完美主义和压力水平。这项研究发现，自我厌恶是——或者说实际上是——完美主义倾向的主要驱动力。人们很少是因为喜欢自己而成为完美主义者的。他们是完美主义者，因为他们在寻找这最后一块
and elusive piece of proof. they actually deserve to be here. And that creates an intense and great deal of stress and pressure. In this way, self-hatred works the same way as any maladaptive coping mechanism. For example, if you drink a lot to counteract social anxiety, yes, you may feel more confident in the moment, but the next day, this only fuels your anxiety more. And it actually doesn't do anything to improve your baseline level of confidence. The same can be said for self-hatred. Again, it may get you to over-prepare for one presentation,
且难以捉摸的证据。他们其实配得上留在这里。这产生了巨大的压力和巨大的压力。通过这种方式，自我厌恶的工作原理与任何适应不良的应对机制相同。例如，如果你喝很多酒来对抗社交焦虑，是的，你可能在当下感觉更自信，但第二天，这只会进一步加剧你的焦虑。而且它实际上对改善你的基线自信水平没有任何帮助。自我厌恶也是如此。同样，它可能会让你为一次演讲过度准备，
it may get you to push yourself harder in one workout, or it may get you to obsess over getting better for one assignment or one exam, but as a long-term strategy, it erodes the very capacity is that you need the most to succeed in the long term, like confidence, like curiosity, like resilience, self-trust, and also the ability to recover after setbacks. Self-criticism is actually consistently associated with diminished goal progress across almost all research, diminished feelings of self-efficacy, diminished feelings of preparedness. One of the best examples of this was five studies done by researchers at the University of
它可能会让你在一次锻炼中更加努力地推自己，或者它可能会让你痴迷于在一项作业或一场考试中表现得更好，但作为长期策略，它侵蚀了你在长期取得成功最需要的能力，比如自信、好奇心、韧性、对自己的信任，以及在挫折后恢复的能力。在几乎所有的研究中，自我批评实际上都一直与目标进展受阻、自我效能感降低、准备感降低联系在一起。最好的例子之一是马萨诸塞大学的研究人员进行的五项研究，他们发现通过自我批评和自我厌恶来激励自己的人，实际上向着他们的目标移动得更慢。相比之下，那些有自我导向标准、并且因为他们想证明自己能做到、因为他们想证明和检验自己的自信、或者因为他们真心享受自己正在做的事情而设定目标的人，则是目标进展的更伟大预测指标。那些同样有自我厌恶的人，他们可能表现出更多的初步进展，但往往会逐渐减弱，因为它不是一个可持续的动力。这一点非常重要，需要记住。尽管，你知道，我们的自我厌恶伪装成拥有高标准，但它们不是一回事。例如，高标准之所以出现，是因为你相信
Massachusetts that found that people who motivated themselves through self-criticism and through self-hatred actually moved slower towards their goals. By contrast, people who had self-oriented standards and who had and set goals because they wanted to prove that they could do it because they wanted to prove and prove their own self-belief or because they genuinely enjoyed what they were doing, this was a much greater predictor of goal progress. The people who had self-hatred as well, they may have shown more initial progress, but often tape it off because it's not a sustainable motivator. And this is really important to remember. Although, you know, our self-hatred is disguised as having high standards, it's not the same thing. Like, high standards occur because you believe
你值得被提升。自我厌恶之所以出现，是因为你相信自己注定成不了你想成为的人。所以我们不能把它们混为一谈，认为它们是一回事。我们不能认为我只是，我只是在给自己施加压力，因为我真的认为我有能力或更多。我只是在给自己施加压力，因为这就像我一直以来做事的方式一样。你可能有一个原因，即你必须继续依赖自我厌恶，你必须继续依赖这种短期、非常强烈的情绪驱动力，因为你没有建立任何实际的长期储备和自尊感，而这些本可以让你高效、有效地实现目标，达到你想要的水平。
you deserve to be elevated. Self-hatred occurs because you believe that you're destined not to be who you want to be. So we can't confuse them and think that they're the same thing. We can't think that I'm just, I'm just putting pressure on myself because I really think that I'm capable or more. I'm just putting pressure on myself because this is just like the way that I've always done things. There's probably a reason why you have to keep relying on self-hatred and you have to keep relying on this short-term, really intense kind of motivator because you haven't built any of the actual long-term reserves and sense of self-worth that would allow you to achieve your goals efficiently, effectively, and to the level that you would want them to.
就像，达到你为自己期望的水平。所以我们在这里稍事休息。然后我们将探讨如何对抗这一点。就像，我们现在有点明白了，这很清楚。自我厌恶是行不通的。那替代方案是什么？因为这实际上可能不仅仅是自爱。我认为它会是，我知道它会是更复杂一点的东西。所以请留下来。自豪就像爱。你在心中感受到它。I-h-r-adio。加拿大排名第一的流媒体应用程序，提供广播和
Like, to the level that you want for yourself. So let's take a short break here. Then we're going to get into how we can counteract this. Like, we kind of know now, like, it's pretty clear. Self-hatred isn't going to work. what's the alternative? Because it actually might not just be self-love. I think it's going to be, and I know that it's going to be something a little bit more complicated. So stay with us. Pride is like love. You feel it in your heart. IR. Radio. Canada's number one streaming app for radio and
播客，包括iHeart Pride Canada，你最喜欢的热门歌曲和必备派对金曲，加上个性化和精心策划的播放列表，比如当年的骄傲。随时随地带上自豪。只需让您的智能音箱播放iHeart Pride Canada。在您的手机上流式传输我们，或立即在iHeartRadio.ca收听。在那一刻，感觉就像永远在继续。我以为我活不下去了。我吓坏了。
podcasts, including IHart Pride Canada, your favorite hits and must-have party bangers, plus personalized and curated playlists like back in the day pride. Take pride with you anytime, anywhere. Just ask your smart speaker to play IHart Pride Canada. Stream us on your phone or listen now at iHeartRadio.ca. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified.
那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变得漆黑。这把我吓坏了。那是你的第一起谋杀案吗？是的，对。害怕说这是你职业生涯中最大的案件吗？是的，先生。强奸杀害一个孩子。
There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, yeah. Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a child.
她是你能遇到的最坏的人。我想是的。人们醒醒。我是那个看到克里瓦奇和德皮波发生谋杀案的人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出丝毫悔意，在被判处最高刑罚时显得无动于衷。我说我无罪。我要将上诉进行到底。
She's as bad as it gets. I would think so. People wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevette and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听“恶魔采石场”。播客。并在苹果播客上订阅Lava for Good Plus，免费收听带有独家内容的“恶魔采石场”。嘿，我是霍达·科特比，播客“霍达·科特比的快乐101”的主持人。在一起，我们将与世界上最迷人的人进行有意义的对话，比如当女演员奥利维亚·穆恩分享她是如何克服严峻的健康挑战时。我经历过乳腺癌，然后帮助我母亲度过了乳腺癌，那更困难。有很多人了解产后抑郁症。
Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Podcasts. And to hear the devil's quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to Lava for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression.
我没有为产后焦虑做好准备。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听霍达·科特比的“快乐101”。因为他们的明星新星是哈维尔·T·托里托·埃尔南德斯。每个人都把我当成足球运动员，但在成为任何东西之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系共存。我出生以来的情绪。我仍然有这么多的问题。我们从哪里来？
I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Because their new star is Javier T. Torito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships. emotions ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from?
死后会发生什么？你如何处理取消文化？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴萨？从日常和普通到深刻和非凡。这不是一个普通的播客。
What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Barza? From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast.
这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的和真诚的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行深度的谈话，脆弱性暴露无遗。阴谋论最终被摆上桌面，目标和教训也被分享。生命中的一切都有完美的秩序，一切都是公正的。
Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has an order perfect and all is just.
等一下，我要有压力，但我将要连接。奇查里托。哦哈维尔
Wait, I'm going to pressurably, but me I'm going to connect. The Chicharito. Oh Javier
埃尔·查查·兰格斯，与IHA广播电台一起。我们将化平凡为非凡。保持密切关注。
El Chachar Rangels and together with IHA Radio. We're going to make the ordinary extraordinary. Stay close.
这是一个卡拉克。哇。在iHeart Radio、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听“学习做人”。主流
It's a carac. Wow. Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcast. Mainstream
主流媒体充斥着无家可归者的身影。充满羞辱和指责的故事。把无家可归者描绘成铁板一块。“我们无家可归”是改变这一现状的播客。我是蒂奥·亨德森，创作者兼主持人。多年来，我创造了一个空间，
Mainstream is full of the unhoused. Stories that shame and blame. and paint the unhoused as a monolith. We The Un-House is the podcast that's changing that. I'm Theo Henderson, creator, and host. And for years, I've created a space
让无家可归者和他们的倡导者可以讲述他们自己的故事。仅在过去的几个月里，我就采访了无家可归的父母、移民、互助组织者、退伍军人、LGBTQTIA+群体，以及制定影响无家可归者生存法律的政策制定者。
where the un-housed and their advocates can tell their own stories. In the last few months alone, I've interviewed unhoused parents, immigrants, mutual aid organizers, veterans, the LGBTQTIA plus community, and the policymakers who make the laws that impact the unhoused existence.
“我们无家可归”是一个荣获两项韦比奖和信号奖的节目，未来还有许多令人兴奋的嘉宾。本周收听我对乔·维希勒博士的采访，她是一位从街头医生转变为网红的人，她对无家可归者社区的工作在网上和她的社区产生了巨大影响。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听“我们无家可归”。当我们恨自己时，我们失去了很多，因为我们隐性地觉得自己不那么配得上。我们隐性地觉得自己能力较差，隐性地觉得自己没那么幸运。显然，保持一点谦逊是极好的，也是非常重要的，而且我认为这也让我们看起来不那么像个混蛋。但当它只是纯粹的自我厌恶时，那很快就会变成无意识的自我破坏。
Weidian Houses a two-time Webby and Signal Award-winning show with many exciting guests on the horizon. Tune in this week for my interview with Dr. Gio Wichler, a street doctor turned influencer whose work with the unhoused community has made a huge impact online and in her community. Listen to Weillen House on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. We lose a lot when we hate ourselves because we implicitly feel less deserving. We implicitly feel less capable and we implicitly feel less lucky. Now obviously, having a little bit of humility is great and is very, very important and I think also allows us to not seem like an asshole. But when it is just pure self-hatred, that quickly turns into unconscious self-sabotage.
我早在刚开始做播客的时候就做过一整集关于自我破坏的节目，所以我可能需要做一点温习，但自我破坏本质上是我们通过制造不尝试的借口、通过推迟决定、在其他人有机会为我们拒绝之前拒绝自己来保护自己免受可能的失败，因为我们无意识地相信无论如何他们的拒绝是不可避免的。现在，你可能会对自己说，你知道的，我不会申请那份工作，因为无论如何我可能不会得到它，因为我不配。就像，我不会去和那个人说话，因为他们可能永远不会感兴趣。我不会发布那个东西，发布我关心的内容，创办企业，推出课程，
I did a whole episode on self-sabotage like way back when I first. started the podcast, so I may need to do a little bit of a refresh, but self-tabotage is essentially when we protect ourselves from possible failure by creating excuses to not try, by delaying a decision, by rejecting ourselves before anyone else gets the chance to do it for us, because we unconsciously believe their rejection is inevitable anyways. Now, it might be that you say to yourself, you know, I won't apply for that job because I probably, I'm not going to get it anyways because I'm not worth it. Like, I'm not going to go talk to that person because they're probably never going to be interested. I'm not going to post that thing, post the content that I care about, launch the business, launch the course,
要求，像，做任何我真正认为重要的事情，因为那样我就得发现我一直都不配。那样我会感到尴尬。当它失败时，我会被评判。这就是自我破坏如何通过阻止我们尝试来制造厄运。罗彻斯特大学的研究表明，自我破坏伴随着真正的心理成本。随着时间的推移，它加剧了适应不良。它降低了能力满足感，这意味着我们即使在成功时也永远不快乐，因为我们总是认为这只是一种侥幸。它与消极情绪、药物滥用以及更低的
ask, like, do anything that I actually think is important because then I would have to find out that I didn't deserve it all along. Then I would be embarrassed. Then I would be judged when it failed. that is how self-hatred creates bad luck by stopping us from trying. Research from the University of Rochester shows that self-sabotaging comes with real psychological cost. Over time, it reinforces maladjustment. It reduces competence satisfaction, meaning that we are never happy even when we do succeed because we always think that it's some kind of fluke. And it's linked to negative mood, substance abuse, and just lower
整体内在动机有关，因为你从不尝试。即使你确实成功了，我们认为这是一种侥幸，但在我们不成功的许多情况下，因为我们从不尝试，你永远不会收集到新的证据来证明你对自己那些批判性的想法是错误的。因此，旧的消极信念没有受到挑战。你不会知道也许他们会说是。你不会知道也许你已经准备好迎接那个新角色，但也许人们真的很喜欢你。也许在你问那个问题的那一端有一个惊人的机会。唯一保持真实并在你因自我厌恶而自我破坏时得到强化的真理是，你的内在批评者是有帮助的，它是管用的，而且事实证明它是正确的，因为，看，
overall intrinsic motivation because you never try as well. Even if you do succeed, we think that it's a fluke, but often in the situations where we don't, because we never try, you never gather the new evidence that those critical thoughts about yourself are wrong. And so the old negative belief stays unchallenged. You do not learn that maybe they would have said yes. You do not learn that maybe you were ready for that new role, but maybe people do really like you. Maybe there was an amazing opportunity on the other side of you just asking that question. The only truth that remains true and that is reinforced when you self-sabotage because of self-hatred is that your inner critic is helpful, is that it is useful and it was correct after all because, look,
你失败了。看，什么也没发生。瞧，它是在试图保护你。自始至终这都是结果。至少你在过程中没有让自己难堪。我认为自我厌恶的另一个代价，除了你总是输的事实之外，是它消耗了难以置信的时间。老实说，比我们在忙碌生活中可能拥有的时间还要多。如果你总是高度警惕并监控你的声音、你的外观、你的表现、你的表现或你的被感知方式，并且你正在使用如此多的注意力资源，这些资源本可以用于实际生活。当你的注意力陷入自我监视时，你就会停下来，
you failed. Look, nothing happened. See, it was trying to protect you. That was going to be the outcome all along. At least you didn't embarrass yourself in the process. I think the other cost of self-hatred, other than just the fact that you always lose, is that it consumes an unbelievable amount of time. Honestly, more time than we probably have in our busy life. If you are constantly hypervigilant and monitoring how you sound, how you look, come across, perform, or are being like perceived and you are, you're just using so many attentional resources that could have gone into actually living. When your attention is trapped in self-surveillance, you stop,
不再沉浸于你自己的生活。你不再真正保持在场，而只是开始表演。单单是事后猜测，字面上的事后猜测，就会把你平常用来思考和行动的每一秒钟加倍。另一件需要小心的事情是，自我厌恶会向外泄漏。我们已经讨论了很多关于这个内在批评者的个体代价，但羞耻感有一种方式会变得具有极大的关系毒性。当人们沉浸在长期的自我蔑视和自我厌恶中时，他们可能会变得更加易怒、更具防御性、更具比较性，我认为可以肯定地说，更有可能投射到别人身上，因为我们更有可能被我们在周围人身上看到的特质所威胁。我们更有可能感到受到威胁，尤其是受到那些
being in your own life. You stop actually being present and you just start performing. The second guessing alone, literally second guessing, it doubles every second second you would normally spend just thinking and acting. Another thing to be cautious of is that self-hatred can leak outwards. We've spoken a lot about, you know, the individual cost of this like inner critic, but shame has a way of becoming very relationally toxic. When people are so wrapped up in this chronic self-contempt and self-hatred, they may become more irritable, more defensive, more comparative, and I think it's safe to say more likely to project onto others because we're more likely to feel threatened by the traits we see in those around us. And we're more likely to feel threatened, especially by the
我们被教导在自己身上进行惩罚的特质的威胁。所以我们看到一个真正喜欢自己的人，我们会想，好吧，为什么我做不到？为什么我没有那个机会？我要因此恨他们。2014年发表的一项非常有趣的研究实际上研究了罪恶感和羞耻感在社交结果中的表现方式。他们发现，实际上，虽然罪恶感可以促进更多亲社会行为，但羞耻感与适应不良的社交模式联系更紧密。所以像攻击、退缩、评判，不是因为人们想成为这些东西。他们不想做这些事。他们不想成为那样的人。没有人想成为那样的人。这只是觉得保护自己和保护内在批评者免于不得不承认也许它错了是有必要的。
traits that we've taught to punish in ourselves. So we see somebody who really likes themselves and we think, well, why can't I do that? Why don't I have that opportunity? I'm going to hate them for it. A really interesting study published in 2014 actually looked at the way that both guilt and shame manifest in social outcomes. And what they found was that actually, whilst guilt can fuel more pro-social behaviors, shame was more associated with maladaptive social patterns. So things like aggression, withdrawal, judgment, not because people wanted to be these things. They didn't want to do these things. They don't want to be that person. Nobody wants to be that person. It just felt necessary to protect themselves and to protect the inner critic from having to admit that maybe it was wrong.
也许有一种更好的生活方式，而不仅仅是靠厌恶自己而生存。所以它永远不会只停留在内部。就像一种感觉是沉重而严厉的。自我厌恶会表现在友谊中。它会表现在工作中。它会表现在你的慷慨程度、你的理解力上。它会表现出来，特别是在那些情况下，因为我们开始想，好吧，如果我在折磨自己，如果我对自己的要求如此之高，为什么别人不这样做呢？就像，为什么他们没有感受到我对自己感到的羞耻、悲伤和愤怒？为什么他们对自己感觉良好？我们不想重新审视那个关键指标或身份的关键部分
Maybe there was a better way of living that wasn't just hating ourselves into existence. So it just doesn't, it never stays internal. Like a feeling is heavy and harsh. a self-hatred is going to show up in friendships. It's going to show up in work. It's going to show up in how generous you are, how understanding you can be. It's going to show up, especially in those situations, because we begin to think, well, if I'm killing myself, if I'm holding myself to such a high standard, how come others aren't doing the same thing? Like, how come they don't feel the shame and the sadness and like the anger that I feel about myself? How come they feel good about themselves. And we don't want to rethink that key metric or key part of our identity
或许存在一种更好的生活方式，而不是靠自我厌恶来维系生存。所以这种情绪从来不会只停留在内心。一种沉重而严苛的感觉、一种自我厌恶，终究会显现在友情中。它会显现在工作中。它会显现在你的慷慨程度、你的理解能力上。它尤其会显现在那些情境中，因为我们开始想：‘既然我在折磨自己，既然我对自己的要求如此之高，为什么别人却没有这样做？’比如，为什么他们没有感受到我对自己感到的那种羞耻、悲伤和愤怒？为什么他们能自我感觉良好？而我们却不愿意重新审视我们身份中那个关键的衡量标准或核心部分。
that self-hatred is helpful or useful. We just judge other people for not having it. So this is what we need to be careful of. And it's why I keep reinforcing that, again, hating yourself isn't just counterintuitive to your goals and your progress. It's counterintuitive to your happiness. And the thing that I be most scared of is that the older we get, the more it becomes a neural pattern, right? Because repeated mental habits over time become easier to repeat. At a basic, like, neuroscientific level, learning of any kind, including learning how to hate yourself, just involves repetition. What we repeat is what sticks. This has an actual term in psychology.
自我厌恶是有帮助的或有用的。我们只是在评判别人为什么没有这种情绪。所以这是我们需要小心的。这也是我不断强调的原因，再次说明，讨厌自己不仅与你的目标和进步背道而驰。它也与你的快乐背道而驰。我最害怕的是，随着年龄的增长，它会越来越变成一种神经模式，对吧？因为重复的心理习惯随着时间的推移会变得更容易重复。在基础的神经科学层面上，任何形式的学习，包括学习如何讨厌自己，都只是涉及重复。我们重复什么，什么就会固化。心理学上有一个专门的术语来称呼这个。
It's called long-term potentiation. and it refers to a persistent strengthening of synaptic connections that are used commonly together, meaning that certain pathways become more efficient over time. So when you repeatedly interpret yourself through a lens of loathing, when you constantly replay all embarrassing situations and say, this is proof that I am not worthy and that I'm embarrassing, or when you're constantly scanning your body or your identity for what's wrong with you or you're picking apart your appearance in the mirror, you are practicing a style of self-relation
它被称为长时程增强作用。它是指经常一起使用的突触连接的持久增强，这意味着某些通路随着时间的推移会变得更加高效。因此，当你不断地通过厌恶的视角来解读自己，当你不断地重播所有尴尬的情景并说，这就是我毫无价值且令人尴尬的证明，或者当你不断在身体或身份中扫描自己有什么毛病，或者在镜子里挑剔自己的外表时，你就是在练习一种自我相处的方式。
that becomes neurally reinforced and recognizable. And it therefore makes it easier for the brain to jump to these critical conclusions again and again rapidly in the long run until you don't know anything more or better or different about yourself. And this is where the concept of negative self-referential processing comes in. This is a cognitive bias where people disproportionately focus on interpret events through and recall negative information about themselves and about the world around them because they've essentially trained their brain to do that for them. This is why this is so important to discuss in your 20s.
这种方式会在神经上得到强化和识别。因此，长此以往，大脑就会更容易一次又一次、迅速地得出这些批判性的结论，直到你对自己的了解不再深刻、美好或有所不同。这就是消极自我参照加工概念登场的地方。这是一种认知偏差，人们会不成比例地关注、通过该偏差解读事件，并回忆起关于自己及周围世界的负面信息，因为他们本质上已经训练自己的大脑去这样做了。这就是为什么在二十几岁时讨论这个话题如此重要。
Yes, this may begin in childhood, but like this is the critical time when you get to interrupt this literal pathway of self-criticism. There are certain neuroimaging studies which highlight where this is most evident. They can literally see patterns of self-hatred in like the medial prefrontal cortex,
是的，这可能始于童年，但这是一个关键时期，你可以借此打断这种字面意义上的自我批判神经通路。某些神经成像研究突出了这一点最明显的地方。他们可以字面意义上地看到内侧前额叶皮层等处的自我厌恶模式，
in the posterioric, singular cortex, both areas of the brain that are involved in emotional regulation, ideas about the self, autobiographical memory. This is where these patterns sit and become strong. Research has found
以及后扣带皮层，这两个大脑区域都涉及情绪调节、关于自我的观念以及自传体记忆。这些模式正是在这里驻留并不断加强的。研究发现，
that these areas light up significantly when people think negatively about themselves. This is where your self-hatred is stored. And this is where those narratives become bigger and bigger and bigger over time if you do not interrupt them. Recent reviews further refine this understanding by showing that these patterns involve broader brain networks too. So this is where it starts. It starts in specifically the prefrontal cortex.
当人们对产生消极想法时，这些区域会显着亮起。你的自我厌恶就储存在这里。如果你不加以干预，随着时间的推移，这些叙事就会变得越来越庞大。最近的评论通过表明这些模式也涉及更广泛的大脑网络，进一步完善了这一理解。所以这就是它的起点。它具体始于前额叶皮层。
But then it begins to move out and touch everything. For instance, there was also in the same study, I think, increased connectivity between the default mode network and the salience network, which may explain why internal negative thoughts feel so intrusive and important and hard to break and so subconscious. Over time, again, I really just want to stress this. Repeated engagement in negative self-talk becomes the standard way that we can, think not just about ourselves, but everything. It gets neurally represented in very significant brain regions that influence how we see
但随后它开始向外扩散并影响一切。例如，同样的研究中似乎也指出，默认模式网络和显著网络之间的连接有所增加，这或许可以解释为什么内在的消极想法会让人觉得如此具有侵入性、如此重要、如此难以打破且如此潜移默化。随着时间的推移，我再次真的很想强调这一点。反复进行消极的自我对话，会成为我们看待自己乃至一切事物的标准思维方式。它在非常重要的大脑区域中以神经形式呈现，这些区域影响着我们的看法。
others, influence how we see our goals, influence how capable we are. And that becomes a lot harder to escape the older we get. So how exactly are we going to start unlearning this? Because I feel like that's a very, I feel like I've just thrown a lot of negativity at you and you're probably sitting there being like, well, I guess I'm screwed because this is just who I am and I've always had these thoughts about myself. I'm just a pessimistic person. I don't think that's true. I think you've been trained to feel that way. I think you've been trained to think that that is normal and trained to think that that is your status quo or how you just are. Again, nobody is born hating themselves. Like, literally, giving that child example again. At some point, you switch over,
影响我们如何看待他人，影响我们如何看待自己的目标，影响我们的能力。随着年龄的增长，这种状态将变得更加难以摆脱。那么我们究竟该如何开始戒除这种习惯呢？因为我觉得这——我觉得我刚刚向你们倾诉了大量的负面情绪，你们可能正坐在那里心想，好吧，我想我完蛋了，因为我本来就是这样的人，我一直对自己有这些想法。我只是一个悲观的人。我不认为那是真的。我认为你只是被训练成了那种感觉。我认为你被训练得认为那是正常的，并被训练得认为那是你的现状或者你本来就是如此。再说一次，没有人天生就会讨厌自己。就像，字面意思，再次用那个孩子的例子。在某个时刻，你转变了，
but you can also rewire those patterns over time. I think it's so worth saying, like, again, you are capable of change. All that information I've given you, like, may lead you to believe that once this is entrenched, it is permanent. We know scientifically that is also not the case, as much as we see evidence for it showing up in our minds and showing up in how we treat ourselves. We also see evidence of people unlearning it. you can unlearn self-criticism at literally any stage in your life.
但你也可以随着时间的推移重新布线这些模式。我觉得非常值得一提的是，再次强调，你有能力改变。我给你的所有信息可能会让你觉得，一旦这种模式根深蒂固，它就是永久性的。但我们在科学上深知事实并非如此，尽管我们能看到它在我们的思维中显现，并体现在我们对待自己的方式上。我们也看到了人们逐渐戒除这种习惯的证据。你实际上可以在生命的任何阶段戒除自我批判。
I literally read this amazing op-ed piece a couple weeks ago from this woman who was like 82, I think, and she was talking about how only at 80 years old did she know what it felt like to like herself. Like that was the first time she ever was like, I think I might like myself and she's never looked back. 80, that was the first time. So you're probably in your 20s, maybe your 30s. You have heaps of time.
我几周前读到了一篇非常精彩的专栏文章，作者是一位大约82岁的女性，她谈到直到80岁时她才知道喜欢自己是什么感觉。那可以说是她第一次觉得，“我想我可能还挺喜欢自己的”，而且她从此再也没有回头。80岁，那是第一次。所以你可能正处于二十几岁，或者三十几岁。你还有大把的时间。
And I think it literally goes to show as serious as I'm speaking about this, it is also reversible. The first thing to really ask yourself is, who does this voice actually serve? Because you now know for sure it doesn't serve you, right? You have all the evidence that this isn't benefiting you. I'm not asking where did it come from. That is an important. An important question, but not the question we're asking right now. I'm not asking why does it sound so convincing.
而且我认为这恰恰说明了，尽管我讨论这个话题时语气严肃，但它也是可以逆转的。真正需要问自己的第一件事是：这个声音到底在为谁服务？因为你现在可以确信，它根本不是在为你服务，对吧？你有充分的证据证明这并没有给你带来好处。我不是在问它从何而来。这是一个重要的问题，但不是我们现在要问的问题。我不是在问为什么它听起来那么有说服力。
I'm asking who does it actually serve in this state and moment in your life. Does it help you become more honest? Is it helping you become more connected? Can you give me any evidence that self-hatred has gotten you anywhere? Or does it keep you small, obedient, ashamed, hypervigilant, apologetic, easy to control? Because despite how convincing and real these voices are, there are often just evidence, again, of how our brains have. been trained to please, trained to make others comfortable, not how we actually should be. And if that voice is not serving you, you actually don't need to listen to it. You don't need to
我问的是，在你人生的这个阶段和时刻，它到底在为谁服务？它能帮变得更诚实吗？它能帮建立更多联系吗？你能给我任何证据证明自我厌恶让你取得了什么成就吗？还是说它让你变得渺小、顺从、羞愧、过度警惕、充满歉意、易于控制？因为尽管这些声音听起来多么具有说服力和真实感，但它们往往只是证据，再次证明了我们的大脑是如何被训练去取悦他人、被训练去让别人感到舒适，而不是我们真正应该成为的样子。如果那个声音没有为你服务，你实际上根本不需要听取它。你不需要
keep treating it as gospel. You can start relating to it as a reflex. Every time you hear that self-hatred kind of bubble up, you have to say to yourself, like, this is not factual. This is just a bad lesson that I was taught. This is just incorrect information I was taught. I know better now. The second thing is just to get super rational. Look outward. Again, try and find just one example, just one, of self-hatred actually helping somebody realize their dreams and enjoy their dreams.
把它当作金科玉律来对待。你可以开始把它当作一种条件反射来应对。每当听到那种自我厌恶的情绪在心中隐隐作祟时，你必须对自己说，这并不是事实。这只是我被灌输的一个错误教训。这只是我被灌输的错误信息。我现在更懂了。第二件事就是变得超级理性。把目光放长远。再次强调，试着找出一个例子，哪怕只有一个，看看自我厌恶是如何真正帮助某人实现梦想并享受梦想的。
Honestly, I have been like racking my brain for weeks trying to think of an answer. The only thing I can ever come up with is people who, like, who present self-hatred as something that I actually had to overcome and they now reflect on, not something that helped them. I think a lot about like the people and this is so random but in biggest loser who like hate themselves, get on the show, lose the weight, still hate themselves. Literally just think of the most inspirational person who you admire more than anybody in the world. Did that person you most admire hate themselves into becoming who they are? Do you know anyone whose life genuinely improved over time because they maintained a running commentary of disgust and humiliation and self-loathing about themselves?
老实说，我这几个星期一直在绞尽脑汁地想答案。我能想到的唯一一件事，就是那些把自我厌恶表现为我必须克服的东西、并且现在回过头来看待它的人，而不是说这东西曾经帮过他们。我想到了很多人，这听起来可能有点随机，比如《最大赢家》（The Biggest Loser）里那些讨厌自己、参加节目、减掉体重、却依然讨厌自己的人。想象一下那个你比世界上任何人都更崇拜的、最具鼓舞人心的人。那个你最崇拜的人，是通过讨厌自己才成为现在的他们的吗？你认识谁的生活随着时间的推移而真正得到改善，仅仅是因为他们对自己保持着源源不断的厌恶、羞辱和自我厌恶的内耗评论？
Has it ever made anybody more creative, more open-hearted, more resilient, more talented? Like, if you can find evidence for it, I would love to know, but I just don't think there is any. Self-hatred survives partly by pretending, again, to be practical and self-serving, and that's how it persuades us to keep it around, because it will keep you humble, it will keep you polite. It will keep you, it will keep people liking you. But you can still be humble and polite and not hate yourself. It's just called self-awareness. So challenge it on those same practical grounds. Self-hatred makes a practical argument. You need me to be a good person. You are saying to it, actually, no, I don't. I don't have any evidence that you've actually helped me.
它有没有让任何人变得更有创造力、更豁达、更有韧性、更有才华？如果你能找到证据，我很乐意知道，但我只是觉得根本没有。自我厌恶之所以能存活，部分原因在于它伪装成实用且利他的样子，这也就是它说服我们把它留在身边的方式，因为它会让你保持谦逊，让你保持礼貌。它会让你、让别人喜欢你。但你依然可以保持谦逊和礼貌，而不必讨厌自己。这不过叫做自我意识。所以，用同样的实用逻辑去挑战它。自我厌恶会提出一个实用的论点：你需要我来成为一个好人。而你要对它说，其实，不，我不需要。我没有任何证据表明你真的帮过我。
I have heaps of evidence that self-love has helped me, but no evidence for you. And I know that I can continue being all the things I want to be without needing to rely on you. I know this is such a commonly said phrase, but you cannot hate yourself into loving yourself and you cannot hate yourself into changing. All of the psychology says it. All of the motivational psychology, motivational architecture will say the same thing. The third step is to give the little mean voice a name and an identity. We spoke about this in our loving yourself will make you more attractive episode, which is honestly a great companion episode to this one if you're enjoying this ep, you can listen to that one after. And it sounds silly, but giving that voice a name,
我有大量的证据证明自爱帮助了我，但没有任何证据证明你帮过我。我知道我可以继续做我想成为的所有事情，而不需要依赖你。我知道这是一句经常被说起的话，但你无法通过讨厌自己来学会爱自己，你也无法通过讨厌自己来改变自己。所有的心理学都这么说。所有的动机心理学、动机架构都会表达同样的观点。第三步是给那个刻薄的小声音起个名字并赋予它一个身份。我们在“学会爱自己会让你更具吸引力”那一集里谈到过这个，如果你喜欢这一集，那一集其实是一个很好的伴侣篇，你可以之后去听那一集。这听起来可能很傻，但给那个声音起个名字，
giving that horrible, nagging, mean voice a name that tells you that you're embarrassing and you don't look gray and you're not smart enough, calling it Kevin, calling it Sarah, calling it Brian, whatever, allows you to separate yourself from the thoughts that you're having. It's just a thought. It's not true. when the thought appears, the self-hating thought, attributing it to something that almost feels outside of you, almost feels like another character that's coming in and interrupting the vibe and like getting in your way creates cognitive distancing. It means that you can rationally examine the thought because it doesn't hold as much self-truth as if it was coming from you all about you
给那个可怕的、唠叨的、刻薄的声音起个名字，那个声音总是告诉你你很尴尬、你看起来气色不好、你不够聪明，叫它凯文（Kevin），叫它莎拉（Sarah），叫它布赖恩（Brian），随便什么名字，都能让你将自己与脑海中的想法分离开来。这只是一种想法。它不是真的。当这个想法出现时——那个自我厌恶的想法，把它归咎于某种几乎感觉像是发生在你之外的事物，几乎感觉就像是另一个打乱氛围并阻碍你的角色的闯入，这会产生认知距离。这意味着你可以理性地审视这个想法，因为它不像它是从你内心出发、全部针对你那样具有那么强烈的自我真实感。
absolutely true. Instead of fusing with the critical voice and those words that seem to just appear unconsciously. Naming it and giving it an identity just gives you some control. It gives you enough distance to choose whether you want to listen to it, to ask whether this voice is actually yours, or whether it is a bully or a panicked younger version of you, or a perfectionist teacher or a cruel parent who got in your head way too early for you to have any say in it.
这绝对是真的。不要与那个批判性的声音以及那些似乎凭空无意识出现的词语融为一体。给它命名并赋予它身份，能赋予你一些控制权。它能给你足够的距离，让你去选择是否要听取它，去质问这个声音究竟是不是你自己的，还是说它是一个霸凌者、一个惊慌失措的年轻时的你、一个苛刻的老师、或者是一个残酷的父母，他们在你根本无法做主的极早时候就已经闯入了你的脑海。
I think something that also helps us have more empathy is to remember that this voice, often the reason it appears is to protect us. It is trying to keep us safe. It's trying to encourage us to act in ways that avoid judgment or avoid external criticism. So a nice practice for this is, yes, call out the voice, give it a name, be like, you're a bully, Brian. But also, I know this may sound counterintuitive, thank the voice a little bit as well. the reason that it came up, the reason that it's here, the reason that it started was because it thought it was helping you. It thought that it was a way that it could prevent you from being
我想，另一件能帮助我们产生更多同理心的事情是记住，这个声音之所以出现，通常是为了保护我们。它正试图让我们保持安全。它试图鼓励我们以能够避免评判或外部批评的方式行事。所以针对这一点的一个好练习是：是的，大声指责那个声音，给它起个名字，对它说“你是个霸凌者，布赖恩”。但同时——我知道这听起来可能有些反直觉——也要稍微感谢一下那个声音。它之所以会出现，它之所以存在，它之所以开始这样，是因为它以为它在帮助你。它认为这是一种能阻止你被
judged or making mistakes. If it was harsh on you first, then, you know, the world wasn't going to be harsh on you second or at all. So thanking it, appreciating it, saying like you've done your job, now it's my turn, I can handle it from here. Also as a way of relating to your voice is something that is, yeah, a bit of a bully but also trying to do its best, meaning that you can kind of move past it, meaning that you can kind of put it to rest. You don't need this coping mechanism anymore. As we've said, you've got all the evidence you need now that it's not as helpful as you think, but also that you can be wise, smart, humble, kind, all those things. You can prevent yourself from embarrassing yourself through self-love rather than that.
评判或犯错的方法。如果它对你严厉在前，那么，你知道，世界就不会对你严厉在后，或者根本不会对你严厉。所以感谢它，感激它，对它说“你已经完成你的工作了，现在轮到我了，从这里开始我可以自己应付”。这也作为一种与你内心的声音相处的方式，虽然它有点像个霸凌者，但它也在尽力做到最好，这意味着你可以某种程度上超越它，这意味着你可以某种程度上让它安息。你不再需要这种应对机制了。正如我们所说，你现在已经有了所需的所有证据，证明它并不像你想象的那样有用，而且你也可以变得明智、聪明、谦逊、善良，做到这一切。你可以通过自爱来防止自己陷入尴尬，而不是依靠
than just self-hatred. So we're going to take one more short break here before we get right back into it. Pride is like love. You feel it in your heart. I-R-Radio, Canada's number one streaming app for radio and podcasts, including I-Heart Pride Canada, your favorite hits and must-have party bangers, plus personalized and curated playlists like back-in-the-day pride. Come together, celebrate love. Take pride with you anytime, anywhere. smart speaker to play iHeart Pride Canada. Stream us on your phone. Or listen now at iHeartRadio.ca.
单纯的自我厌恶。因此，在我们深入探讨之前，这里我们要再进行一次简短的休息。骄傲就像爱。你在心中感受得到它。I-R-Radio，加拿大排名第一的广播和播客流媒体应用程序，包括I-Heart Pride Canada、你最喜欢的热门歌曲和必备的派对神曲，以及个性化和策划的播放列表，例如重温昔日骄傲。欢聚一堂，庆祝爱。随时随地，彰显骄傲。使用智能音箱播放iHeart Pride Canada。在手机上流式传输我们。或立即在iHeartRadio.ca上收听。
In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir.
那一刻，感觉仿佛过了一个世纪。我当时以为自己活不成了。我吓坏了。那些眼神里空洞无比。它们的颜色变黑了。这把我吓了个半死。那是你的第一起谋杀案？是的，先生。
Fair to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a child of 12-year-old. She's as bad as it guy. I would think so. Evil, wake up. I'm the woman that saw the murder take place by Creveit and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse,
可以公平地说，这是你职业生涯中最大的一起案件吗？是的，先生。对一个12岁孩子的强奸谋杀案。他跟那家伙一样坏。我想是的。恶魔，醒醒。我就是那个目睹克里瓦茨（Creveat）和德皮波（DePippo）实施谋杀的女人。安东尼·德皮波（Anthony DePippo）没有表现出丝毫悔意，
appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear the devil's quarry ad free with exclusive content, Subscribe to Love for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby.
在被判处最高刑期后显得无动于衷。我说我没有犯罪。我会把这带进坟墓。在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《恶魔采石场》（The Devil's Quarry）。要收听无广告且包含独家内容的《恶魔采石场》，请在Apple Podcasts上订阅Love for Good Plus。嘿，我是霍达·科特比（Hoda Kotb），播客《霍达的101种快乐》（Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb）的主持人。
Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people. Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the podcast. the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. It's a part of the surprise to me because their new star is Javier T. Torito Hernandez.
在这里，我们将与世界上最迷人的人物进行有意义的对话。就像当女演员奥利维亚·穆恩（Olivia Munn）分享她如何克服严峻的健康挑战时。我经历过乳腺癌，然后又帮助我母亲度过乳腺癌，那更加困难。有很多人理解产后抑郁症。但我并没有为产后焦虑做好准备。在播客中收听《霍达的101种快乐》（Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb）。the IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。这对我来说是个惊喜，因为他们的新星是哈维尔·T·托里托·埃尔南德斯（Javier T. Torito Hernandez）。
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi?
每个人都把我视为一名足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。从我出生起，每一天我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系、情绪共存。我仍然有这么多的疑问。我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？你如何应对被取消资格？是C罗还是梅西？
Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Barza. From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where vulnerability comes out.
外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴萨。从日常与平凡到深邃与非凡。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的每一件事都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行一场深入的交谈，脆弱感在这里流露。
Conspiracy theories end up on the table, and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has an order perfect and all is just. Wait, me, I'm going to be able to be. We are here to connect. The Chicharito. We are Javier. We're going to make the Ordinary.
阴谋论最终被摆上台面，目标和人生经验也被分享。生命中的一切都有着完美的秩序，一切皆是公正。等等，我，我将能够成为。我们来到这里是为了建立联系。小豌豆（The Chicharito）。我们是哈维尔。我们将让平凡变。
We're going to make the ordinary. extraordinary, extraordinarily. Stay close. It is a carac. Listen to learning to be human on IHard radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Mainstream media is full of crude depictions of the unhoused,
我们将让平凡。变得非凡，无比非凡。保持关注。这是个特色。在IHard radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《学习成为人类》（learning to be human）。主流媒体充斥着对无家可归者的粗俗刻画，
stories that shame and blame and paint the unhoused as a monolith. We The UnHouse is the podcast that's changing that. I'm Theo Henderson, creator and host, and for years I've created a space where the un-housed and their advocates can tell their own stories. In the last few months alone, I've interviewed unhoused parents, immigrants, mutual aid organizers,
那些让人感到羞耻、指责并将无家可归者描绘成一个单一刻板群体的故事。《我们，无家可归者》（We The UnHouse）是一档正在改变这种现状的播客。我是创始人兼主持人西奥·亨德森（Theo Henderson），多年来，我一直为无家可归者及其倡导者创造一个可以讲述他们自己的故事的空间。仅在过去的几个月里，我就采访过无家可归的父母、移民、互助组织者、
veterans, the LGBTQTIA plus community, and the policymakers who make the laws that impact the unhoused existence. Woody and House is a two-time Webby and Signal Award-winning show with many exciting guests on the horizon. Tune in this week for my interview with Dr. Jill Whitcher, a street doctor turned influencer whose work with the unhoused community has made a huge impact online and in her community. Listen to Wey &House on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. If you want to stop hating yourself or stop normalizing self-hatred,
退伍军人、LGBTQIA+社群，以及制定影响无家可归者生存状况的法律的政策制定者。《我们，无家可归者》（We The UnHouse）是一档两度荣获威比奖（Webby）和信号奖（Signal Award）的节目，未来还有许多令人兴奋的嘉宾登场。本周收听我与吉尔·惠彻（Jill Whitcher）博士的采访，她是一位从街头医生转型为网红的医生，她对无家可归者社群的工作在网络和她的社区产生了巨大的影响。在IHard radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《我们，无家可归者》（Wey & House）。如果你想停止讨厌自己，或者停止将自我厌恶归为正常现象，
this may be the hardest thing in the episode to do, but you've got to stop hanging around people who think that putting you down is normal, or who think that talking about how much they hate themselves is an appropriate conversation, especially when they almost like expect you to contribute. We've spoken a lot about like what you need to do internally. Your external environment also matters. Obviously, it's super normal to talk about our insecurities with our friends and to get support. But obsessing over your insecurities, collectively, without any resolution, almost as a
这可能是这一集中最难做到的事情，但你必须停止和那些认为贬低你是正常的人混在一起，或者停止和那些把谈论自己有多讨厌自己当作得体对话的人交往，尤其是当他们几乎像是期待你也能插话附和的时候。我们已经讨论了很多关于你在内部需要做什么。你的外部环境也很重要。很显然，和朋友谈论我们的不安全感并寻求支持是再正常不过的事情了。但是，在没有任何解决方法的情况下，集体沉迷于你们的不安全感，几乎将其作为一种
form of social bonding is not normal. And friends who think putting you down, especially physically, is fun or banter. I don't know who hurt you. That's not something that friends are meant to do. I had this particular friend who was so incredibly insecure that she would almost include me in her insecurity and in her self-deprecating comments she made about herself. If she saw like a really beautiful girl, if we were out together, she would be like, oh my God. me and you could never look like that or like wow we could never pull that off or we'd go shopping and she'd be like well people like us can't wear that people like us can't shop at those stores and it would make me feel like absolutely horrendous about myself so much so that even after
形式的社交纽带，这就很不正常了。而且那些认为贬低你（尤其是针对身体外貌）很有趣或只是开玩笑的朋友，我不知道是谁伤害了你，但这根本不是朋友该做的事。我曾有这样一个朋友，她极其没有安全感，以至于她几乎会把我卷入她的不安全感以及她对自己的自我贬低中。如果我们走在一起时看到一个非常漂亮的女孩，她会说，天哪，我和你永远不可能长成那样，或者说，哇，我们永远驾驭不了那种风格。或者当我们去购物时，她会说，像我们这样的人可穿不了那种衣服，像我们这样的人可不能去那些商店买东西。这让我对自己感到绝对的糟糕透顶，以至于即使在
I'd mentioned it a few times she didn't stop and I just had to stop going out with her in those particular ways and in those environments like I didn't want to to normalize that way of thinking about myself. I loved her. I still do love her deeply, but that kind of attitude was not one that I needed any more of. I don't need to be included in your self-hatred. Like at that point I had enough of my own. There are some people that, you know, for whatever reason, will always, I don't think this was her intention, this is separate, but there are some people who will always put you down, whether it's insecurity on their behalf or some other part of themselves they're not comfortable with,
我提过好几次之后她还是没有停下来，我只能停止和她一起去那些特定的地方、参与那些特定的社交活动。我不想把那种看待自己的方式当作理所当然。我爱她。我至今依然深爱着她，但那种态度是我不再需要的。我不需要被卷入你的自我厌恶中。因为在那时，我自己的自我厌恶就已经够多的了。总有些人，无论出于什么原因，总是——我不认为这是她的本意，这是另一回事——但总有些人总是会贬低你，无论是出于他们自身的缺乏安全感还是他们对自己身上其他不满意的地方，
they will involve you in their own self-hatred because it feels less lonely and it feels more normal. Sometimes entire relationships seem to be held together by mocking, disguised as honesty, and not just mocking each other but others, strangers, mutual friends. in those spaces, this is why self-hatred feels so normalized, right? Because self-respect saying, actually, I really like myself and I really think that person looks great and maybe we shouldn't talk like that can sometimes feel arrogant or like you're embarrassing them. So we stay quiet,
他们会把你也拉进他们自己的自我厌恶中，因为这样会让他们觉得没那么孤独，觉得这更正常。有时候，整个关系的维系似乎都靠着伪装成诚实的嘲讽，不仅是互相嘲讽，还嘲讽其他人、陌生人、共同的朋友。正是在这些空间里，自我厌恶才会让人觉得如此习以为常，对吧？因为自尊——说出“其实，我真的很喜欢我自己，我真的觉得那个人看起来很棒，也许我们不应该那样说话”——有时可能会让人觉得你很傲慢，或者觉得你在让他们感到尴尬。所以我们保持沉默，
we get used to being nasty to ourselves, we almost adopt a nastier persona as a way of gaining social approval. There's also this weird social ritual we see all the time where like somebody insults themselves and then you feel obligated to insult yourself in return as if like self-rejection is how we maintain that closeness. You just don't have to participate. You can just not say anything. Someone else's self-loving does not require you to join in. That is, that does a lot of damage more than I think we can afford in a society that wants us to hate ourselves constantly. how our friends treat us, how they treat themselves is really psychologically powerful. There's an osmosis, there's a transference that happens when we are close to somebody emotionally
我们习惯了对自己恶言相向，我们甚至为了获得社会的认可而采用了更加刻薄的人格。还有一种奇怪的社交仪式，我们经常看到，比如某人贬低自己，然后你就会觉得有义务也贬低自己作为回应，就好像自我排斥是我们维持这种亲密关系的方式一样。你根本没必要参与。你完全可以什么都不说。别人的自爱并不需要你加入。这造成的伤害远比我们想象的要大得多，在一个总是希望我们讨厌自己的社会里，我们无法承受这种代价。我们的朋友如何对待我们、他们如何对待自己，在心理上具有真正强大的力量。当我们在情感上与某人亲密接触时，会产生一种渗透作用、一种转移作用，
where we can feel their pain and we can feel their self-hatred and it is reflected onto us. And again, that's not to say, like, cut off everybody who isn't as far ahead and they're like self-love journey as you are. But just be aware of it. keep tabs on whether it's infiltrating you and don't be afraid to just not participate or be, just say, I'm sorry, but that's not what I feel and I don't talk about myself like that. And I don't think you deserve to think those things about yourself either. So maybe this is a good place to start. Maybe our friendship can be like a self-loathing free zone.
在那里我们能感受到他们的痛苦，也能感受到他们的自我厌恶，并且这些情绪会被反射到我们身上。再次强调，这并不是说要跟所有在自爱之旅上没有你走得那么远的人断绝来往。但只要保持觉察就行了。留意这种情绪是否正在渗透进你的生活，并且不要害怕选择不参与，或者直接说：“对不起，但这不是我的感受，我不会那样谈论我自己。而且我认为你也不该那样看待你自己。”所以这或许是一个很好的起点。也许我们的友谊可以成为一个“无自我厌恶区”。
And I know that can be an very awkward conversation because sometimes it can feel like holier than now or like you're scolding them. Yeah, maybe it will feel like that. Maybe that's how they will interpret it as well. But I think it's worth having boundaries around the language that people use with you as a way to also maintain boundaries around the language that you use with yourself, especially considering everything we've spoken about today and how important it is. The fifth thing I would suggest is also just keep an ongoing list of what you like about yourself and add to it as much as possible. every day, if not once a week, to almost aggressively prove to yourself you are worth liking and you are worth feeling proud of. This list tip uses like this simple, attentional trick
我知道这可能是一场非常尴尬的对话，因为有时这会让人觉得你自命清高或者是在训斥他们。是的，也许它会让人觉得尴尬。也许他们也会这样解读。但我认为，围绕他人对你使用的语言设定界限是值得的，这也是为了对你自已使用的语言设定界限，特别是考虑到我们今天所谈论的一切以及它是多么重要。我要建议的第五件事是，也请列一份关于你喜欢自己的长处的不间断清单，并尽可能地为之添砖加瓦。每天，如果不止一次就一周一次，近乎执着地向自己证明：你值得被喜欢，你也值得感到骄傲。这个列清单的小建议运用了一个简单的注意力技巧，即：
that what we focus on expands. Think of it like when a biased researcher looks only at evidence that like confirms their hypothesis. That is what I want you to do. When we're in the mindset of self-hatred, like that's what's happening in reverse. We only pay attention to the negative evidence. And we think that that must mean it's the truth and that that must confirm everything that our inner critical voice is saying missing like 50% of the picture. Flip it. Reverse it. Instead, try to create a really deliberate, ongoing set of reasons or pieces of evidence why you are amazing, why you care about yourself, why you are a productive person, and why you deserve to feel proud of your achievements,
我们关注什么，什么就会扩大。把它想象成一个有偏见的的研究人员，只去寻找那些能够证实其假设的证据。这就是我希望你做的事。当我们处于自我厌恶的心态时，情况正好相反。我们只关注负面的证据。并且我们认为这一定意味着这就是真相，这一定证实了我们内心的批判声音所说的一切，从而遗漏了50%的全貌。把它翻转过来。逆转它。相反，试着创造一组真正深思熟虑的、持续更新的理由或证据，证明你为什么很棒，为什么你很在乎自己，为什么你是一个富有成效的人，以及为什么你值得为自己的成就感到骄傲，
why you look amazing, why people like you. It should be like the small granular details that make you who you are. You make people feel less awkward. You are observant. You make people laugh. Dogs always seem to want to be near you. I feel like that one's an amazing one. You keep your word.
为什么你看起棒极了，为什么人们喜欢你。它应该是一些让你成为你自己的微小细节。你让别人不那么尴尬。你很善于观察。你把别人逗笑。狗狗似乎总是想靠近你。我觉得最后这个真的是绝了。你言出必行。
You're a good friend. That really forces us to focus back in on everything that society has kind of said, we don't get to acknowledge. because if we were to acknowledge that, we would be arrogant, we wouldn't be humble, we would be, I don't even know. Like, again, once you interrogate this a little bit further, you kind of realize how deeply impractical it is. Like, it doesn't actually work. It doesn't actually make us like ourselves.
你是个好朋友。这真的迫使我们重新将注意力集中到社会曾告诉过我们“我们不被允许承认”的所有事情上。因为如果我们承认了这一点，我们就会显得傲慢，我们就会不够谦逊，我们就会变得……我甚至不知道。同样，一旦你对此进行更深入的审视，你就会发现它是多么的不切实际。它其实并没有用。它其实并不能让我们喜欢自己。
It doesn't actually make us better people. Who is it benefiting? It's benefiting people who get to sell us things, get to sell us products, get to sell us surgeries that stem from a socially conditioned self-hatred, and it benefits people who like it when you are small and don't stick up for yourself. So I think that's kind of all I have for this episode. I think I have a few more things, but like I feel like I need to do a part too.
它其实并不能让我们成为更好的人。这究竟在让谁受益？它让那些向我们兜售商品的人受益，让那些向我们兜售源于社会规训的自我厌恶的手术的人受益，它让那些喜欢你变得渺小、不敢挺身而出的人受益。所以我想这就是我这一集要讲的全部内容了。我想我还有一些别的事情要说，但我觉得我需要录制第二部分。
I hope this is just as much as it's been a ranty episode, been kind of informative and persuasive that you need to get more serious and you need to be more spooky about, interrupting your thoughts of self-loathing because they are not, A, an accident or be harmless. They deeply infiltrate what we think we deserve, how we behave, how we motivate ourselves, and how we connect with others. And if we're not careful, especially during this formative period of our lives, they can become the entire basis of our self-belief, meaning that the older we get, the harder it comes to reverse, not impossible, but the harder it becomes. And eventually we kind of
我希望，正如这一集充满了吐槽一样，它同时也充满信息量且富有说服力，能让你意识到你需要更加认真对待、并且需要对打断你的自我厌恶想法保持警惕，因为它们既不是A偶然发生的，也不是B无害的。它们深深地渗透进我们认为自己配得上什么、我们如何行为、我们如何激励自己以及我们如何与他人建立联系之中。如果我们不够小心，尤其是在我们生命中这个形成关键期，它们会成为我们自我信念的全部基础，这意味着随着我们年龄的增长，逆转它就会变得越发困难——并非不可能，但会变得更加困难。最终我们会坐下来，
sit around, survey our lives and realize all the things I've missed out on have come from the fact that, like, way back when when I was a kid, somebody said I didn't deserve to like myself and I thought that they were true, despite all the other evidence that I have every reason to like myself. And that even the reasons that I have not to like myself aren't as important as the reasons that I do have. So I think that's all we have time for. I hope that if you made it this far, you enjoyed this episode, share it with a friend if you think that, I don't know, if you think they can relate. I don't know, if you think that they could benefit from some of the research and some of the things that we discussed. Remember that if you are listening to the episode, you can also watch it on Netflix. And if you are listening and you've
审视我们的人生，并意识到我错过的一切都源于这样一个事实：很久以前，自我还是个孩子的时候，有人说我不配喜欢自己，而我居然信以为真，尽管我有所有的其他证据证明我完全有理由喜欢自己。甚至连我那些不该喜欢自己的理由，也远不如我该喜欢自己的理由那么重要。所以我想这就是我们所有的全部时间了。我希望如果你听到了这里，你会喜欢这一集，如果你觉得……如果你觉得他们能感同身受的话，就把它分享给朋友吧。如果你觉得他们能从我们讨论的一些研究和事情中受益的话。请记住，如果你正在收听这一集，你也可以在Netflix上观看它。如果你正在收听并且已经
made it this far, leave a little love heart emoji down below so that I know that you are a loyal listener. You can also follow us on Substack. I'm going to post the full transcript of this episode if you want to, I don't know, absorb it in a different format. And you can also follow us on Instagram as well if you want to contribute your thoughts about self-hatred as a complex, your thoughts about societal self-hatred over there. But until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. There was no anything inside. those eyes. They turned black.
听到了这里，请在下方留下一个小爱心表情符号，好让我知道你是一个忠实的听众。你也可以在Substack上关注我们。我将发布这一集的完整文字记录，如果你想……我换个格式来消化它。如果你想分享你对作为一种复合情绪的自我厌恶的看法，以及对社会性自我厌恶的看法，你也可以在Instagram上关注我们。但直到下一次，保重，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。里面没有任何东西。
It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum.
那些眼神。它们变黑了。这把我吓了个半死。恶魔，醒醒。我就是那个目睹克里瓦茨和德皮波行凶的女人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出丝毫悔意，
I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcast. Joy is essential and it's also elusive. But now, there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101.
在被判处最高刑期后显得无动于衷。我说我没有犯罪。我会把这带进坟墓。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《恶魔采石场》（The Devil's Quarry）（属于Bone Valley Feed系列）。快乐至关重要，却又难以捉摸。但现在，有一种全新且激动人心的方式来开启通往更快乐生活之旅：《霍达的101种快乐》（Joy 101）。
It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby is presented by C. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born.
这是一个全新的播客，由我——霍达·科特比主持。如果你渴望获得最大化快乐的灵感，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的空中对话。打开您免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索Joy 101并立即收听。由C赞助播出的《霍达的101种快乐》（Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb）。每个人都把我视为一名足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。从我出生起，每一天我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系、情绪共存。
This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine, just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Jirnandez and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHare Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? That is not the look of an innocent man. Is everyone lying to me about who they are? I felt such desperation.
这不是一个普通的播客。这里的每一件事都是自发的、真实的、真诚的，只是一些关于活着意味着什么的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·埃尔南德斯（Javier Hernández），请在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《学习成为人类》（Learning to Be Human）。每个家庭都有秘密。但是，当你发现你的父亲一直在过着双重生活时，会发生什么？那可不是一个无辜之人的眼神。每个人都在对我的身份撒谎吗？我感到了极度的绝望。
I felt it was what I had to do. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is. getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is, getting a new one put up in its place. I'm Akela Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 is about both of those things. As I was watching these statues come down,
我觉得这就是我不得不做的事。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《深层卧底：顾家男人》（Deep Cover the Family Man）。有些事情本不该如此复杂，比如：
I was thinking about what it meant that I grew up in a majority black city in which there were more homages to enslavers than there were to enslave people. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
拆除一座种族主义雕像。而有些事情本该容易得多，比如：在原地竖起一座新的雕像。我是阿克拉·休斯（Akela Hughes），《叛逆精神》（Rebel Spirit）第二季探讨的就是这两件事。当我看着这些雕像被拆除时，我一直在思考，我在一个黑人占多数的城市里长大，那里对奴隶主的致敬比对被奴役之人的致敬还要多，这意味着什么。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《叛逆精神》（Rebel Spirit）第二季。这是一个IHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。